[music]
Myra Gupta:
The title of this play is "Dial 'M' for Marriage: A Murder at an Indian Wedding." And it's actually
PSAT's first forage into the murder mystery genre because we read this news article about
Myra Gupta:
a murder at an Indian wedding over the summer and we thought, "Hey, that'd be a great idea
Anjali Bisaria:
for a play!"
PSAT is the nation's first and oldest South Asian acting group. We were founded in 1999
Anjali Bisaria:
by grad students at Princeton along with some undergrads. And since then we've been putting
on original plays. We write two original plays every year.
Myra Gupta:
We're one of the only theater groups that actually does that.
Anjali Bisaria:
We focus on South Asian culture and heritage and the shared experience of Indians and South
Asians in both the states and in India.
Myra Gupta:
And usually through the lens of humor because these issues can get a little heavy sometimes
and we like to take a comedic approach to it.
PJ Das:
There's absolute pandemonium in this house. I can't stand it a minute longer.
Myra Gupta:
Right after the bride, Amita, has found that the pandit has been murdered at the pooja before the wedding,
she's getting ready for bed, and she's also expressing some of her
Myra Gupta:
nervousness about getting married and of course the fact that someone was murdered at her
wedding to her sister, and her maid is helping her tweeze her eyebrows because she
Myra Gupta:
wants to make sure everything is ready for the wedding.
Shloka Mehta:
So, Amita, I guess the big question here is: Are you still getting married in two days?
Rachita Jain:
Of course I am. At least, I think so. I'm not sure how things will work out from here on...
Nobody has ever been murdered at my wedding before... OUCH! Bai, that hurt!
Sanchali Pal:
Arrey, Beti, your eyebrows are a jungle! Deforestation is not without pain!
Anjali Bisaria:
What's great about a murder mystery is, at a wedding, is that we actually get to incorporate
a lot of different aspects of South Asian culture that we don't normally get to, like:
Anjali Bisaria:
large families, ridiculous food, ridiculous parties, all those kinds of things ...
Myra Gupta:
... crazy relatives, over-the-top accents, all of that fun stuff.
Anjali Bisaria:
All of those things that are quintessential to a wedding, and we can really
bring that together.
Sanchali Pal:
So first, we will cleanse your aura and remove the essence of the murder. Animbu pani swati om shanti nami nazar ...
Shloka Mehta:
This is going to be a great success!
Myra Gupta:
I'm really glad this is on film. We love each other in PSAT! We love each other!
This is embarrassing.
Anjali Bisaria:
Haha. This is actually on film? Haha.